Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cecilia Bernabeni
Il ponte.
C'è una connessione
fra l'immagine di un ponte,
che è qualcosa che, quando attraversiamo,
ci porta da uno scenario a un altro,
e l'idea di futuro,
che è qualcosa che, quando arriva,
ci porta da un presente a un altro.
Conosciamo bene alcuni ponti:
ad esempio, immagino
che gli abitanti di Bassano
conoscano bene questo ponte.
E quando conosciamo bene un ponte,
è difficile che, una volta attraversato,
ci ritroviamo in un nuovo scenario
che ci sorprende.
Ma alcune volte non conosciamo il ponte.
E in questi casi,
può capitare che attraversarlo
significhi ritrovarsi
in uno scenario inaspettato.
Anche questo sembra vero del futuro.
Molto spesso, il futuro è banale,
forse addirittura noioso.
In molti casi, sappiamo bene
cosa capiterà domani a noi.
Ma alcune volte non è così.
È facile trovare esempi, se pensiamo
agli ultimi episodi della nostra vita
legati alla pandemia:
sono sicuro che ciascuno
di voi avrà vissuto,
avrà dovuto cambiare i propri progetti
o addirittura cancellare
qualche evento che voleva fare.
Ad esempio, questo
è un esempio molto personale.
Io a giugno dovevo sposarmi
con il mio compagno, che è di Hong Kong.
Dovevamo sposarci
a Barcellona, dove viviamo.
Ora immaginatevi recuperare
tutti i documenti,
chiamare gente da più o meno
due continenti -
non ci siamo ancora riusciti.
Se questa immagine del ponte
è un'immagine così buona del futuro,
se è in qualche senso
una metafora completa del futuro,
uno potrebbe chiedersi perché mai -
è anche molto naturale pensare
che il futuro si possa cambiare.
Ora, io penso che il futuro
non si possa cambiare.
E cercherò di spiegarvi perché.
Ma nel contempo, penso anche
che non sia qualcosa
di cui dobbiamo aver paura.
Dunque, perché penso che il futuro
non si possa cambiare?
Innanzitutto, quando noi diciamo
che "il futuro è cambiato",
molto spesso quello che,
in effetti, stiamo dicendo
è che la storia che ricopre
il ruolo del futuro
non è quella che ci aspettavamo,
che in un certo senso
ci siamo sbagliati rispetto al futuro.
In questo senso, quindi,
parlare di cambiamento
è semplicemente usare una metafora.
Vi faccio un esempio
per spiegarvi esattamente perché:
è un esempio su cui ero un po' titubante,
ma poi ha fatto sorridere
così tanto gli organizzatori
che mi hanno convinto a tenerlo.
Io ho un'amica, Sara,
che cambia spesso fidanzato.
E Sara ha, diciamo,
quello che si dice "un tipo":
cioè un uomo sulla trentina,
sportivo, in genere.
L'altro giorno, io e il mio compagno
invitiamo Sara a cena.
E si presenta con un uomo distinto,
sulla cinquantina,
non particolarmente sportivo.
Quando mi ritrovo in cucina,
da solo col mio compagno,
dico al mio compagno: "Hai visto?
il fidanzato di Sara è cambiato!".
Ovviamente, stavo facendo una battuta;
e quello che stavo dicendo veramente
è che la persona che ricopre
il ruolo del fidanzato di Sara
aveva delle caratteristiche
che non ci aspettavamo.
Ma se le cose stanno così,
se questo è ciò
che veramente stavo dicendo
parlando di cambiamento
in questo senso metaforico,
perché non pensare la stessa cosa
anche del futuro?
Perché non pensare che, quando diciamo
che "il futuro è cambiato"
quello che stiamo dicendo, in effetti,
è semplicemente che ci sbagliavamo
rispetto a quello
che sarebbe stato il futuro?
Qualcuno potrebbe obiettare che,
anche se questo è vero,
c'è una differenza fra il caso
in cui, diciamo -
c'è una differenza fra dire
"il futuro è cambiato"
e "noi abbiamo cambiato il futuro".
Magari, cambiare il futuro
non è una cosa facile:
e questo lo si vede dal fatto
che, molto spesso, ci impegniamo
per poter cambiare il futuro:
iniziamo una dieta, prendiamo un mutuo,
facciamo un corso
per imparare una lingua straniera
o dipingere sulla ceramica;
e ovviamente, sembrerebbe
difficile spiegare
perché facciamo tutte queste cose -
che ci costano fatica, spesso -
se non pensassimo
di poter cambiare il futuro.
In fondo, se i nostri successi
sono già nel futuro,
allora basta che ci sediamo
e aspettiamo: prima o poi, arriveranno.
Se non sono già nel futuro, invece,
potremmo fare qualsiasi cosa
ma non arriveranno.
Anche questa maniera di pensare
penso non sia corretta.
Il punto è che, anche se
il futuro non si può cambiare,
questo non vuol dire
che il futuro sia indeterminato.
In filosofia contemporanea,
spesso si raffigura
l'idea di indeterminatezza
in termini di possibilità
o alternative future.
Il futuro è indeterminato
nel senso che ci sono
molte alternative future,
ce ne sono più di una.
E in questo senso,
il futuro è fondamentalmente
diverso dal passato,
che invece è unico.
Per esempio, io stamattina
ho fatto colazione al bar.
Sono andato al bar; ho ordinato un caffè;
l'ho bevuto; l'ho pagato;
e poi, sono uscito.
Se io guardo al passato
da dove sto ora, dal presente,
quello che vedo è una linea
dove ogni evento è seguito
da uno e uno solo altro evento.
Ma se io dal presente guardo
non solo al passato, ma anche al futuro,
quello che vedo non è tanto una linea
ma piuttosto qualcosa come un albero.
Prendete ad esempio questo presente:
io mi trovo qua, davanti a voi,
con le mani in avanti.
Questo presente potrebbe essere seguito
da un futuro in cui alzo la mano destra
o un futuro in cui alzo la mano sinistra.
Potete scommettere: cosa succederà?
Facciamo così: alzo la mano sinistra.
In un certo senso,
prima che il futuro arrivasse
c'erano due opzioni:
c'era Giuliano che alza il braccio destro,
e Giuliano che alza il braccio sinistro.
Il futuro era composto da due alternative:
e in questo senso era indeterminato.
Ora, qualcuno potrebbe dire: appunto!
Tu, con le tue azioni,
lo hai cambiato, lo hai reso determinato,
sei passato da qualcosa
di indeterminato, con due opzioni,
a una cosa determinata
come il passato, con un'opzione.
Ma anche questo non è totalmente corretto:
in un certo senso,
le due opzioni sono, sì, uguali;
entrambe avrebbero potuto capitare;
ma di fatto solo una è capitata,
solo l'opzione
braccio sinistro è capitata.
Alcuni filosofi parlano del futuro,
sulla base di queste considerazioni,
come di una sottile linea rossa.
L'idea è che, per quanto
dal punto di vista del presente
il futuro sia costituito
da molte alternative,
il futuro sia alla fine una linea.
Perché?
Perché di futuro ce n'è solo uno.
Solo uno si realizzerà.
Ossia è una linea, che è rossa
perché si distingue dalle altre;
ma è anche sottile,
perché non è fondamentalmente diversa
dalle altre alternative.
Tutte le altre alternative,
in particolare se andiamo a vedere
quelle che contengono le mie azioni,
saranno tali per cui quello che ho fatto,
se ho avuto successo, di fatto,
non è stato sufficiente.
Quindi, dal punto di vista
di questa metafisica del futuro,
di questa idea di che cosa sia il futuro,
il futuro è una serie di eventi
che coinvolge i miei tentativi,
i miei successi;
ma, ahimè, talvolta
anche i miei fallimenti.
In questo senso,
il futuro non si può cambiare.
Ma questo non vuol dire
che, per quanto possibile,
il nostro destino
non sia nelle nostre mani.
Grazie.
(Applausi)